[Music]
we escape death
then came to it
[Music]
and that is God's will he says
they transported two bodies in this
vehicle exactly where we're sitting now
in the back seat and there's still body
bags that they use to move them across
and into Syria to be buried and now
they're heading back into morass to see
if there are any more
the drive feels longer than usual
this is where they're going to see if
the seven loved ones that they have
underneath this Rubble are going to be
pulled out
Muhammad and his family moved here from
Syria 10 years ago his Aunts Uncles and
cousins fled the war and all lived along
this road
some have been found alive and others
not
I asked him if he has any hope
this is the building here
[Music]
he's operating on sheer faith
his three young cousins are buried in
this building and he climbs it with
determination
as bodies are pulled out all around him
foreign
the call to prayer sounds and marks the
start of a long evening
one that is tense with anticipation
these guys are prepared to be here all
on the cousin lean in a little bit
closer to see if they can spot their
loved ones
[Music]
Muhammad loses patience and gets in
himself
calls out for the three sisters that
live in the same room
[Music]
sham
this name
no response
[Music]
and then a small lifeless hand
but they keep digging for her sisters
the youngest sister is alive
[Music]
victory
[Applause]
sham is carried out to safety
foreign
survived days under the rubble
her older sister follows
Muhammad sat in the front seat of the
ambulance ready to go to the hospital
and make sure that his cousin gets
through this alive and to think that
just earlier he's come back from the
border after transporting the bodies of
his uncle and his other cousins to be
buried
sham later died in the hospital
three sisters one found dead one found
alive and one still buried horror
happiness and then heartache all in one
day
[Music]
Sky News